Before we go and optimize it's important
to understand that these optimizations
are only meant for production.
Sure you could execute them all
the time, but it would dramatically slow
down your iterative build time, and thus
make live editing a lot less powerful.
Instead I recommend to split your
tasks into development and production.
Development tasks contain things
you really need no matter what.
Sass processing, for example, and tasks
that only make sense through encoding,
for instance, live editing.
However, keep in mind
that while developing,
this means you'll be using a different
version of your app than your users.
It's going to look and feel mostly the
same, but sometimes performance issues
or bugs only manifest with
a specific optimization technique.
So make sure to always test the
production version from time to time.
In our next couple of instructions,
we'll be creating more generated assets.
Previously, the only generated files
we were producing were the CSS files.
But now we need to create
a structure to hold production and
development files separately.